you shall not pause Gauss clever um
probably the first one to come up with
that one The Hobbit the Battle of five
armies that's a lot of [ __ ] armies
this is the third installment to the
hobbit trilogy the first one I thought
was boring the second one I actually
really enjoyed this third one was
there's okay all right good if you want
to know what this movie is it's one long
action sequence I'm all for like
cinematic escapism like you know a
visual feast action and just an epic
music like that's all fun and nice
whatever if that's all you really want
then you'll walk away satisfied maybe
even more than satisfying like the
ladies but honestly I couldn't help but
get a little too bored a little too
often don't get me wrong there are good
things about it I just walked away
really focus on what I didn't like about
it for starters I was just kind of
pissed off by the time the movie was
over it was literally mad I punched the
baby sitting next to me cuz the baby
when he showed up the whole time had
nothing to do the movie like the first
10 minutes of this movie could have been
the last 10 minutes of part 2 and by the
time this movie was done I was like you
did not need to be three movies this
could have easily been too I really feel
like this movie lacked an emotion now I
could do a whole video of comparing this
franchise to the Lord of the Rings and
honestly whenever I do that I just end
up liking the hobbit trilogy less and
less but can one really be playing for
comparing them I mean it's based on
books by the same author and it's from
the same director and at times this
movie seems so self aware that it's a
prequel to Lord of the Rings it's really
their fault you compare it so [ __ ] them
not me most one [ __ ] me but I got a
girlfriend so back the [ __ ] up but let
me do my best to charge us take into
talking about this one movie the Battle
of five armies sometimes has more
character than the first two films let's
face it that's really not saying much
the number one complaint about these
movies lately is that Peter Jackson
cares less
a character and so much about visuals
like my favorite thing out of this
trilogy is Bilbo Baggins the [ __ ]
Hobbit but early on in this franchise I
felt like they just kind of pushed his
character to decide he does like three
themes in this movie and he's really
just used to like move the plot along
but like by the end of his journey I
felt like it wasn't that rewarding it's
not like a heroic adventure tale of this
guy he's like someone who just tag along
for the adventure and helped out every
once in a while but I really can't
complain about the casting of Bilbo
Martin Freeman still my favorite thing
out of this trilogy I just feel like
these films would have been better if we
got more focused on him Thor in the king
of adorbs he annoyed the [ __ ] out of me
oh man I haven't read the book so I
don't know whether or not to blame this
complaint on [ __ ] source material or
on the writers of this movie but
regardless Thorin to me has always been
an annoying little [ __ ] huh a little
bit because he's a dwarf and it's a
rather two-dimensional performance it's
not three-dimensional imagine if the
performance was four-dimensional holy
[ __ ] would that even be like if I were
to read a description of this guy they
probably read tough brooding [ __ ]
leader and that is all he does is just
play those little qualities like he's
supposed to be the leader the king and i
would see anything of this dude being a
leader i'd want to follow someone i'd
want to rely on he seems like a selfish
dick like all the time and yet something
happens where it becomes nicer and
whatever but did I really have to go
through two and a half movies to [ __ ]
get there although there is this like
big action scene with him and I thought
was pretty [ __ ] awesome like we've
wanted it where he fights the big pale
orc like that was a cool scene most of
those armies in the Battle of the five
armies exist because he's a [ __ ] dick
he's the main character I should be
rooting for him he's really not that
likable I just want someone to punch him
in his face or seen some dwarves X I
think this movie would have been a lot
better if we had some dwarf sex my
favorite moments in this movie were
actually the scenes that were not trying
to be super happy not because I'm some
analytical douchebag filmmaker wanna be
the best moments are when they just let
the actors do their job like have
conversations and shrew interaction with
each other it's like whenever its
characters are having a real talk with
each other this visually epic film is
actually at its best why
it's not doing that visual stuff this is
movies like look at big week and me
everything tries to be so grand in scope
like it's one thing to look epic it's
another thing to have a feel epic for
something to feel epic you gotta have
real investment in the characters I felt
like this was just about moving the plot
along and finding more ways to get
action sequences in there so yeah if
you're going mainly for the action this
movie's jam-packed with it so you're
gonna be happy it just likes so much an
emotional investment that I I was zoning
out during battle sequences the only
thing worse than that is zoning out
during porn that's when you know you got
a problem and the nods to the Lord of
the Rings like how they delved into
Serrano at that time I didn't find it
necessary in this franchise it just
wasn't necessary the way they wrapped it
up in this third one like it was a cool
visual sequence but by the time is done
I was like I didn't learn anything new
not saying it was bad it just wasn't
necessary I know I said I wouldn't
compare our Lord of the Rings but I keep
[ __ ] do it anyway but come on I mean
that trilogy had amazing character and I
felt the visuals were even better
whenever there was CGI it was the right
amount of CGI but a lot of it was like
practical effects which made the world
feel more authentic this trilogy kind of
felt like a cartoon I just feel that
after having great characterization
backed up with awesome visuals and cool
action in Lord of the Rings they should
have honored the concept of how
important character is in this trilogy
as well it's hard trying to sound
intellectual so in conclusion this film
is a great technical achievement but
it's just really lacked and grabbing a
hold of your emotions so I wasn't even
moved by the visuals damn it Peter
Jackson what that happen to you it's cuz
you've lost that weight and get the fat
back man let me get straight to the
point here The Hobbit the Battle of five
armies got it emotionally wrong
alright guys thanks for checking out my
review for the hog at the Battle of five
armies once you go to that comment box
and tell me would rather have sex with
the dwarf or a hobbit they're different
you know yeah they're both short but
ones hairier than the other and you know
it might mean to the hair do you think
I'm not but you might and last but not
least if you want to get updated every
time one of my reviews are videos this
out go ahead and click on this button I
might take this subscribe that's right
the dick let me tell you something about
this little hobbit every time he whips
himself out the little hobbit girls say
that's the biggest how that I've ever
seen it because hobbits are short and
I'm following my penis a hobbit and
they're saying it's a big Hobbit same I
got a big penis you know what you try
coming up with a dick joke every [ __ ]
movie review you do
if you liked this film good for you good
for you doesn't make me wrong does make
you wrong it's just the way you feel I
can't wait for how many people are going
to call me a [ __ ] for not like in this
movie